hello everyone
i hope you got a slice of pizza
so my name is enrique
i don't usually get quotes but i
recently relocated in new york this
paper
from sydney australia where i was living
for seven years
i'm originally from italy
last time i did a presentation in sydney
it was like half the people and
a quarter of the size
but double time the beer so and we
usually do presentation in pumps in
sydney
so if you if you go there you should
definitely jump the crew it's it's
pretty nice
um
so i worked with ruby and wales for the
last nine years and this book that i'm
giving is about uh real scientists who
feature powerful parts of this
application
so i've separated out various
application components in engines before
when working on
application dealing with complex
momentum
this app didn't have one
it started as a monolith
but
a curious requirement okay
so um the app had those um
two parts really an admin user interface
and a public user interface uh it was
under development for a couple of months
for a total of five developers working
on it
a requirement came in to a rounded
product and public portions of the
atlanta separate service
the reason for it was a policy to lock
administration interfaces behind the vpn
as well as
stopping the admin deployments affecting
the public portion of the app
as well as to try and separate out the
load between the two portions
the public being vastly more popular
than the other
the reason behind the requirement change
could be political or technical
but we um
we really know that sooner or later a
change will will happen and it's good to
take an approach that
accommodates that
so we had like um three proposals to
tackle this the first was to go uh
service oriented architecture um where
two applications the admin and the
public we talked to some api
and that felt a bit overengineered
we didn't answer how to share user
interface components within this public
in the army in any way
the second proposal was to have
to separate the components of the app so
have a shared
ui domain logic and have two
applications using those jams
we knew that our developments with
custom can change those components
meaning we're using a new gem every
admin or public update
we would also have to update our
workflow to ensure that the gemfile.log
won't be pointing to the local gems
and not to check that integration
control
the third proposal was to uh use um
local rails engine components so to
identify and separate the relevant
components from the application
and to move them in rails engine
this solution would diverge a little
applications um later in the
presentation i'm going through a few uh
a few things that
and a few problems and a few solutions
to those
um so i've done this before and it felt
like it was a solid stepping stone if
later we wanted to go full service
oriented architecture
so we knew about the public and the army
portions
so we started looking for their
boundaries in the source code
so the target was to have two engines
serving the two portions
and be able to mount them
programmatically from the main
application routes which is this part
here
the app running model value that you can
see is just a proxy to an environment
variable handling a fallback in case of
local development
so admin announced admin public public
analysis
app running modes is the only class that
will leave in the main
rails application everything else will
be inside the engines
and this is an example of how
the server will be run so if you set
this running mode equals administrator
that's on the
on the
super secret
product domain and the public one is
just just as running mode equals public
and locally when you just want to test
both without having to create and type
to service one you can just omit that
variable
so that's the objective now this is a
quick description of what rails engines
are
there will be jams
there are special ruby champs that
provide actual behavior
a combination of model views routes red
tasks to address applications that can
be hosted on a gem server but they can
also leave inside your repository
and that can be tested in isolation
uh so i won't go into the details of
creation creating those engines but i
will point to a link at the end of the
presentation
so instead of focusing on the admin user
interface uh boundary
and
i created a component directory in my
ios application and that's where all the
rails engine will
leave you can call that whatever you
want so sometimes i call it in the
pattern called the engines
basically i'll switch to components
so this is the command to create the
engine
like i
said i'll point to the race guy than the
detail of the command uh just uh just a
heads up that command always creates the
engine in the route uh in the root
directory of rails so you need to
manually move it into
components
now the first step was moving the admin
related features stacks from the main
app into the engine
and this is just a heads up but
proceeding without pests could drive you
crazy everything i've done with this was
an unenvironment application so i moved
my specs first and i drove all this
refactoring through that
as i was looking in the code
i identified the shared user interface
elements for some preview shared by
admin and um
and the public
facing part as well as some share domain
so to reduce the usual scope i just
put all that inside the admin ui
so the admin ui engine
is now required by the uh
by the config route you can see this is
like an interim state where the
application relies on the
public routes using regular rights and
then it's mounting the admin ui
now the gem followed the main
application is updated to require the ui
engine
and now the main application was when
fine depending on admin ui so i started
moving the public interface from the
main app into the engine
similarly without me with moving the
feature first
so i created the engine
and now the
main application is relying on the two
on the two engines
and the public ui is now relying on
admin ui because of the shared ui and
the main logic
and this is the genuine stack inside the
public ui engine
you can see in the middle there is that
uh
dependency on administrator
so
this delivers the required functionality
but now the two are glued together
and the public ui
really is tightly coupled to
the public ui
so extracting the domain logic from out
of the admin ui is the next step
and again
i created the main logic
engine and this in my case stores the
documents
in in the past i had storing the active
record models and migrations as well as
other domain logic ruby object used by
both admin and public um
admin and public only classes should not
be built in the hero
and in my engine test mode i am loading
the id the mongodb from the game
application but i'll get into testing
in a little bit
now that
i tackled the shed ui
that i tackled with the main logic the
chevy i was next
similarly i moved files from admin ui
into scheduler
and its purpose
was to holding views and assets shared
by admin and the public engines
so that now both admin and public ui can
use shared ui templates
so those
those shared ui with all only views no
models no controllers no routes and
that's their responsibility
now here's a final look at the main
application in general depending on all
the engines
um when a couple of years ago i started
looking into this i
i was confused because i expected the
admin ui to require the main logic
and it does that
but you can't find that because there
are local dependencies so you must tell
your main application about that
position
so that's something to keep in mind
and
in fact if we remove them uh we will get
an error saying um cannot find jam chat
ui which is required
that is because of the local part
so now i'm going through a few common
pitfalls of this uh reyes engine land
the first is when you are developing
your engine
and you add the dependency to
your other engines
down there you must remember that those
are local dependencies so you will need
to update your engine gen file to point
to those files uh to those locations
another thing related to this is the
required so when we develop with ruby on
rails we we just rely on
bundler to require all the gems that we
have in our gem file
in our case we use a gem stack
so those gems are not required so you
will need to manually require the gems
that your that your engine relies on
then into their testimony if
people has created like engines before
they come with those these tests
it's a real swell up the race
application and you can move in its
folder and run red server or run race
tasks
its purpose is that's your rate of
engineer isolation
so when you test a jam in isolation all
you need is that jam
when you test the waste engine
potentially your leveraging of rails
so each engine has its own um
uh ruby constant
so that when bundle and bundle exec are
spec it's run is in complete isolation
so the um
the look of the um
of my
rails helper at the top
so instead of requiring the raised
surface of coordinated damian
in the conflict with
the bundle gem file the junk folder we
that we require is the one inside the
engine so the rails the dummy rails
application will load uh what the engine
is relying upon
and then a funny thing down at the
bottom is the routes so the application
mounts your engine in that defaults your
admin ui
and that could cause a lot of problems
because you might expect your feature
castings
inside the engine to just mount them in
the same position as you mount them in
the main app but that's not true so you
need to remember to if you mount your
engine on slash admin on
other than that the dummy app is usually
not
not getting touched too much
now testing multiple engines that's
usually done with a build script that
runs a bundle except us back on each
and collects the units unix return code
um recently uh i've got through this
script from uh stefan a guy that works
so capable and
i think i'm i'm gonna use it soon enough
so what what it does it finds the um a
test file uh a bash script and then he
basically runs it um
and collects the results from the main
app so that's actually much sleeker than
my solution variables running manually
and moving android
um
generators use required dependency at
the top
meaning of that is
and i prefer this syntax with a full
namespace application controller in
front
if you don't have that and you just
rely on application controller that
application controller could cause
flicky tasks where in some cases it will
load the main application controller of
the main app in some other case it will
load the engines
and when it's the first case it won't
load some of the outputs that you are
likely to rely on so that's another drop
shot
next is on scaffolding and generators
scaffolding is mostly broken
in when you use it with
namespace model names
so the the next four slides
are about errors that they cause so
there required tennis has the name
station follow it so that was another
final fan
the helpers will be nested directories
so because this problem and this is a
big one about the
about the paths so the url outputs all
are all broken so it's pretty much worth
trying to use generators
uh the mongodb generator uh and again
most of the some of the generators like
this one does something very simple so
it's not even worth looking into why
it's dropping it just creates a file
now
we could have achieved this
uh this separation by
using the same feature flag technique
with regular
raised rods on analytica
the advantage of separating application
concerns in engine or gems
is to make code more maintainable which
is key for a long
lifespan of projects like bigger than a
couple of months
um
it worked work for this
uh if we didn't have the separation
requirement i wouldn't i would have
pulled off on this on this um
on this switch
and wait for more complex rules coming
in the past um i was working
at abc in sydney and we had a project
where
the domain logic was very complex we
were building a framework for game
designers to create hd and element
compass number of games
and that was in conjunction with
university of melbourne there's a lot of
the main logic and rules so that project
we knew from day one was going to be
ongoing and he had a lot of components
so in that case we started from day one
introducing
early could
help you it's really up to you what at
what point you want to to introduce this
kind of architecture
i hope this book will help people
tackling
these sort of problems and generate some
curiosity on the topic and
i'm pretty much done feel free to ask me
questions here or online
any questions
how do you handle like sticky
deployments like migrations
in the past we didn't have like two
databases but
i think what would happen is you run the
migration and we use
so we don't have the problem of
migrations
but i think if i had to use a relational
batteries what i would do is
schedule that deployment on the master
database
and
yeah one thing that i that i didn't
mention was the uh the public
application uh currently it's just like
a regard
but i would schedule like a deployment
for uh let's say that it was a um
database i would schedule the ones for
the outgoing evaluations from that
but it's about a point
yep
um so the question is if um local
development you need to run bundle on
every time
so what happens usually is um
you you like develop mostly in one
engine and then once that's completed
you can move on to the say the audio ui
and at that point so um
i don't because it's pointing to that
file
so the gen fablock is looking at that at
the director so there's no need to do
that
alright well thanks again